meine Lieben visualpolitik Zuschauer
darf ich vorstellen die Republik
kasantep
[Musik]
nur die Ruhe ihr seid nicht im falschen
Video gelandet die Republik kasante ist
kein neues Land jahrelang war die
Republik kasante so etwas wie die Mutter
aller waves eine riesige Strandparty auf
der Halbinsel Krimi die doch Menschen
aus ganz Europa anlockte die Creme waren
nämlich so etwas wie das Ibiza der
Ukraine traumhafte Strände glamouröse
Parties und das alles zu viel
günstigeren Preisen als das eigentliche
Ibiza ja so ging es zu auf der Krämpfe
oder 2014 bevor der Sterne Volkshaus
Vladimir vladim Putin den Dekaden den
Garaus macht
als heiliges Land bezeichnet weil sie
der Ort war an dem Wladimir der große im
Jahr 1998 zum Christen konvertierte und
damit den Grundstein für einen
christlichen orthodoxes Russland legte
wenn allerdings historisches Symbolik
zum Maßstab aller Dinge erhoben würde
dann hätten die Ukraine einen noch
stärkeren Anspruch auf die Krim weil
Wladimir der große nämlich der Herrscher
der kiewars war die vom heutigen Kiefer
aus regiert wurde von einem mein Name
ist Moskau sollte damals noch weitere
150 Jahre niemand was hören und die
Frage ist könnten eines Tages die bunten
Raver und die ausgelassenen Zeiten
wieder auf die Halbinsel zurückkehren so
wie sie selbst wieder in den Schoß des
liberalen und demokratischen Kiew oder
wird Putin in diesem Fall lieber den
Weltuntergang auslösen ganz nach dem
Motto wenn nicht alle nach meiner Pfeife
tanzen dann soll niemand mehr tanzen
können all diese Fragen werden wir im
heutigen zweiten Teil unseres Krim 2
Teilers beantworten in der ersten Folge
konntet ihr alles Wichtige über die
wechselvolle Geschichte der Krimi lernen
die uns bis zum heutigen Punkt geführt
haben falls ihr den ersten Teil noch
nicht gesehen haben sollte dann holt das
jetzt bitte über den Link oben rechts
hinter dem e-symbol oder unten in der
Videobeschreibung nach wenn du dann
werdet ihr den gesamt Zusammenhang
verstehen heute werden wir erklären
wieso die krimfrage so essentiell ist
für den Frieden in Europa ob und wie die
Ukraine sie zurückgewinnen könnte und
wie die möglichen Szenarien sowohl für
die Halbinsel als auch für die Ukraine
Russland und Europa aussehen lasst uns
sofort aber noch einen großen
werbehhinweis unseres Tonnen Sponsors
zur Abschlag einspielen damit wir danach
sofort loslegen können denn surfshark
wie PN ist ein wirklich empfehlenswertes
und sicheres VPN welches zum Beispiel
keinerlei Verbindungsdaten mit lockt
natürlich kann ein worcial private
network-netzen lassen und wissen was man
tut aber es stellt hierfür ein Werkzeug
mit gleich mehreren Vorteilen da zum
einen erschwert ist in Kombination mit
anderen Vorkehrungen eure Aktion im
nächsten Jahr zu verfolgen und abzuhören
mit Hilfe verschiedener Sicherheit könnt
ihr so eure Anonymität im Netz erhöhen
z.B mit dem integrieren wird das alle
unerwünschten Cookies und Power blockt
beitrone könnt als während ihr in einem
anderen Ort so könnt ihr zum Beispiel
Webseite
seid nicht verfügbar werden ob daheim
oder im Urlaub damit schlagt jetzt sind
nur und dir blocking ein Schnäppchen
Netflix und anderes
anbieten von Europa oder deutsches
Internet gucken willst du auf ja kein
Problem aber das ist noch lange nicht
alles
wirklich alle eure Endgerät registrieren
Handys Notebooks oder sogar Smart TV so
und Rabattcode Politik die angeht
bekommt ihr von surfshark auch noch ein
Rabatt in Höhe von 83% und oben dran die
ersten drei Monate gratis dazu den Link
zu diesem Angebot findet ihr in der
Beschreibung unter diesem Video also
nicht sie los besorgt als Server schauen
gerade damit auch gleichzeitig uns
finanziell unter die Arme das könnt ihr
übrigens auch direkt mit Hilfe des
Spenden links den ich ebenfalls in die
Videobeschreibung gepackt haben wir sind
euch für jede Unterstützung dankbar denn
damit hätten sie uns euch in Zukunft
noch mehr und noch bessere Videos zu
liefern so und nun lasst uns auf eine
Reise aufbrechen auf der wir die
Gegenwart und Zukunft der Krim und ihre
Rolle in Europa unter die Lupe nehmen
werden auf geht's
[Applaus]
[Musik]
unser Vergleich zwischen der Creme und
Ibiza war gar nicht mal so abwegig der
die Krim war vor 2014 nicht nur eine
tolle Partyinsel nein auch aus
politischer Sicht war sie eine Art Insel
innerhalb der Ukraine Politik schon
länger schaut wisst ihr bereits dass
dieses Land in zwei große
Bevölkerungsgruppen geteilt war die
russische sprachige und die Ukraine
sprachige der beste Beweis dafür sind
die Wahlen in der Region mit mehr Rose
streichen Einwohnern siebten in der
Regel Parteien und Kandidaten die der
russischen kulturnährer standen und in
der Regel generell kremlaffiner waren
und wir sehen könnt haben die Bewohner
der Krim eher Parteien gestimmt die sich
auf die Fahne geschrieben haben
ethnische Russen zu repräsentieren denn
dort sprechen auch fast 95% der
Bevölkerung Russisch aber Achtung mit
der perspektor Michael kehrten auch
viele der vertretenden Kindertagen in
die angestammte Heimat ihrer Vorfahren
zurück und 2014 also kurz vor der
russischen Invasion lebten wieder
200.000 von ihnen auf der Halbinsel
trotzdem lieben die ethnischen Russen
mit rund anderthalb Millionen gegenüber
den ca 700 000 übrigen
schaut sich in der Vergangenheit eben
bei allen Wahlen bemerkbar gemacht
sowohl bei den Parlaments als auch bei
den Präsidentschaftswahlen allerdings
gab es dort trotz der Sympathie in der
Krim Russen für Moskau nie einen
nennenswertes separatistische Bewegung
selbst Putin erklärte noch 28
unmissverständlich dass die Krim Teil
der Ukraine sei und bleiben sollte und
das Russland keinen Anspruch auf sie
erhebe doch das alles sollte sich in der
Nacht bis 21 februar 2014 vollkommen
ändern also Viktoria der von Russland
unterstützte Präsident der Ukraine mit
einem Hubschrauber aus kieflow
monatelange pro europäische Proteste im
Zentrum Kios hatten eine gewalttätige
Wendung genommen als er seine
Scharfschützen das Feuer auf die
Menschenmenge eröffnet hatten doch diese
ließ sich nicht einschüchtern und
Vertrieb den Präsidenten der in ihren
Augen zu Vaterland Verräter und
kremlagenten geworden war auf der
kriminierten der Wald pro russische
Separatisten mit hipsten und Tataren
aneinander letzte waren Anhänger der
Revolution in Kiew tja und dann tauchten
plötzlich die berühmten kleinen grünen
Männchen auf russische Streitkräfte auf
der Creme wer sind sie und woher kommen
sie am 27 februar 2014 nur sechs Tage
nach januaris Flucht schickte Russland
Truppen ohne hoheitliche Kennzeichnung
auf die Krim da sie nur grüne Uniformen
ohne Insignien und Erkennungszeichen
Drogen wurden sie als die kleinen grünen
Männchen bezeichnet im Klartext heißt
das aber das Russland militärisch auf
die Krim einmarschiert ist es aber bis
vor kurzem einfach nicht zugeben wollte
120 Soldaten des russischen Militär
Geheimdienstes u besetzten schnell das
Parlamentsgebäude und unter Anwesenheit
der schwer bewaffneten russischen
Spezial Einsatzkräfte setzen die
Christen Parlamentarier hinter
verschlossenen Türen den demokratisch
gewählten Ministerpräsidenten der
autonomen Republik Grimm Anatom
den Vorsitzenden eine obskur und
russischen Partei zu ihrem neuen
Premierminister und das obwohl er bei
den vorangegangenen Wahlen gar keine
Chance gehabt hätte zu gewinnen aber das
war erst der Anfang denn anschließend
beschlossen sie eilig eine Referendum
über den Anschluss an Russland
abzuhalten Wahllokal standen natürlich
vorsichtshalber bis an die Zähne
bewaffnete russische Soldaten dafür
fehlten aber die internationalen
Wahlbeobachter oh vorsichtshalber das
Ergebnis 97% der Bevölkerung stimmten
für den Anschluss aller Russland und an
dieser Stelle könnte man eigentlich
völlig überflüssig Fragen handelte es
sich wirklich um ein demokratisches
Referendum nun offensichtlich nicht auf
der anderen Seite kann man aber durchaus
davon ausgehen dass ich zumindest eine
großer Teil der Bevölkerung mit Russland
identifizierte schließlich handelt es
sich bei den meisten um ethnische Russen
die selbst oder deren vorfahrenden Zuge
der Russifizierung auf die Krim
eingewandert waren fakt ist die Annexion
löste in Russland eine Welle der
Euphorie aus und wurde auch auf der
Creme von vielen gefeiert allerdings
tausende von grimmbewohnern die er mit
Kia sympatisierten Flo und über die neue
Grenze nach Norden nach russischen Recht
wurde jeder der auf der Grimm wohnte
automatisch russischer Staatsbürger
diejenigen die sich weigerten russische
Pässe anzunehmen wurden automatisch das
rechtsberaubt auf der Grenze arbeiten
eine staatliche Gesundheitsversorgung zu
erhalten oder sogar dauerhaft dort zu
leben die Frage ist nun also eigentlich
wieso Putin eigentlich so nervös war und
es nötig hatte unbedingt mit allen
Mitteln sicherzustellen das was
Referendum eindeutig ausfällt denn
natürlich mussten diejenigen die nicht
dafür waren die klassischen Repressionen
Moskau über sich ergehen lassen
anschließlich grausamer Folterungen
erreichte es ihm nicht dass etwa zwei
Drittel der Wähler ethnische Russen
waren brauchte er wirklich die 97% nun
dann lasst uns doch lieber mal etwas
genauer unter die Lupe nehmen ob die
Menschen auf der Creme wirklich so
glücklich darüber sind ein Teil Russland
zu sein
das teuerste Juwel in Putins Imperium
das erste was die cremebewohner nachdem
bemerkten war dass die Republik kasante
tippt der Rave starb einen schnellen Tod
es kehrte Toten Stille ein oder
Tourismus auf der Krim brach vollkommen
zusammen es waren schwierige Jahre für
die lokale Wirtschaft fast alle
ukrainischen Unternehmen die Halbinsel
belieferten verschwanden über Nacht die
Sanktion des Westens ließen die wenigen
verbliebenen Geschäftsaktivitäten
untergehen und die Unterbrechung der
Wasserversorgung aus der Ukraine drehte
der traditionell bedeutenden
Landwirtschaft auf der Krim regelrecht
den Saft ab die Krim trocknete Jahr für
Jahr regelrecht aus potient war sich
jedoch darüber im Klaren dass sie
Eingliederung der Creme in ein neues
große russisches Imperium oberste
Priorität haben musste
ich habe keinen Zweifel daran dass Putin
sehr daran interessiert ist auf der
krim-ergebnisse zu erzielen das ist über
jeden Zweifel erhaben aber er hat etwas
zu beweisen die russische Nation hat dir
etwas zu beweisen und was müssen sie
beweisen dass sie das Gebiet viel besser
regieren als die Ukraine seitdem hat
Putin auf die klassische Russifizierung
Strategie zurückgegriffen
sofort ein Programm das systematischen
Tyrannei gegen die wieder ansässig
gewordenen
Geld oder Haftstrafen verurteilt während
die kindertarische Sprache und Kultur
die auf dem Papier eigentlich von Moskau
garantiert sind in der Realität des
Alltags auf der Krim an denen Rand
gedrängt werden natürlich hält sich
Putin ähnlich wie bei denen auch hier
ein paar kastrierte Schoßhündchen so
dass eine Propaganda nach außen zum
Beispiel die Neueröffnung einer Moschee
zelebrieren kann offiziell sollen die
Anerkennung muslimischer fester als
nationale Feiertage und des Grimm
tatarischen als Staatssprache auf der
Creme als Beweise für die Unterstützung
durch den russischen Staat gelten dabei
handelt es sich um nichts anderes als
eine zynische Maskerade die die bittere
Realität über Griechen sollen denn Fakt
ist seit 2014 haben 140.000 Verfahren
die Krimi wieder verlassen viele davon
Richtung unbesitzte Ukraine ja und an
ihrer Stelle kamen massenweise Russen
wenn man sich die Berichte von
Menschenrechtsorganisation anschaut wird
offenbar wie ernst ist Putin mit seinem
Stalin Revival zur Creme umfolgung meint
es fängt damit anders klingt totalen die
die russische Staatsbürgerschaft nicht
annehmen wollen regelmäßig verhört
werden ihre Wohnungen dann will
natürlich von der Polizei durchsucht
tatarische Medien in dem Kreml nicht
genehm sind wurden erst schikaniert
schließlich verboten politisch aktive
krimplataren werden als Extremisten und
Terroristen gebrandmarkt willkürlich
verhaftet und gefoltert in der Haft wird
ihnen der Zugang zu notwendige
medizinischer Versorgung gut
ausreichende Ernährung verweigert und es
kommt regelmäßig vor dass diese
politischen Gefangenen an den Folgen
dieser Haftbedingungen sterben tja und
manchmal lassen die Russen ihnen
unliebsame Tataren einfach verschwinden
wohlgemerkt das alles geschieht nicht
erst seit 2022 sondern schon seit 2014
März 2016 die russischen Behörden haben
in den zwei Jahren in denen sie die
Halbinsel besetzt haben einen Klima der
Angst und Repression auf der Krim
geschaffen
dies alles hat die Rosen bei den
trentataren natürlich noch verhaster
gemacht aber dazu kommen wir noch wenn
es um die Rückeroberung durch die
Ukraine gehen wird während den Dritter
taren nämlich das Leben schwer gemacht
wurde wo es nur ging förderten die
russischen Behörden die Umsiedlung von
Russen auf die Krim mit den
vielfältigsten Mitteln vergünstigte
Immobilienpreise günstige Hypotheken und
Kredite materielle Unterstützung und so
weiter und so fort da die Geburtenrate
nach der Annexion der Creme im
durchschnittlich 24% eingebrochen ist
wird die lokale Bevölkerung immer
stärker durch Migranten ersetzt
russischen Welt zufolgezogen zwischen
2014 und 2021 353
000 Menschen auf die Halbinsel das sind
immerhin 15 % der Bevölkerung innerhalb
nur 7 Jahren die überwiegende Mehrheit
der Migranten stand der natürlich aus
den ethnisch russischen Regionen der
Russischen Föderation und vergiss bitte
nicht das sind nur die offiziellene
russischen zahlen die Monitoring Group
von Black News und dem schwarzen
Institut für strategische Studien geht
davon aus dass die tatsächliche Zahl der
Migranten die aus allen Teilen muss
einschließlich Sibiriens auf die Creme
umsiedelten zwischen 800.000 und einer
Millionen Menschen liegen könnte viele
von ihnen haben ihren Erstwohnsitz
nämlich einfach gar nicht offiziell auf
der Creme angemeldet neben den
offiziellen Migranten kam außerdem auch
noch zahlreiche Angehörige des
russischen Militärs Geheimdienstler und
Vertreter der Staats- und
Strafverfolgungsbehörden und natürlich
viele reiche Russen die am gewaltigen
Landraub teilhaben und es sich unter der
schönen schwarzen Personen gut gehen
lassen wollen sie alle kamen natürlich
mit ihren Familien aber diese Kategorien
werden von der offiziellen russischen
Statistik nicht berücksichtigt somit ist
aber klar dass die russische Regierung
seit 2014 bereits zwischen 25 und 40%
Bevölkerung umgefolgt hat aber Putin
weiß natürlich er muss auch dafür sorgen
dass die alten wie neuen Russen auf der
Creme eine akzeptable Lebensgrundlage
haben und aus diesem Grund hat Moskau
seit 2014 Ressourcen aus der ganzen
Russischen Föderation abgezogen um sie
auf der Krim zu konzentrieren so sieht's
aus die Bewohner anderer Teil der
Russland sind über diese Umverteilung
nicht besonders glücklich aber putin war
das Wichtigste dass die Wirtschaft der
Grimm nicht zusammenbricht und sich die
Menschen dort dann gegen ihn wenden
könnten insgesamt wurden offiziell mehr
als 20 Milliarden Dollar an Subventionen
in die Halbinsel gepumpt mehr als der
Kreml in diesem Zeitraum in fast jede
andere Region des infrastrukturellen
sträflich unterfinanzierten Landes
gesteckt hat und inoffiziell dürften die
Zahlen noch wesentlich höher sein
genauso wie die kleinen grünen Männchen
schickte Putin also auch viele kleine
grüne Scheinchen auf die Creme damit
nicht auffällt wie schlecht es wirklich
um ihre Wirtschaft steht und wie
abhängig sie von Moskauer drauf ist und
das wohl Symbol prächtigste Projekt der
gesamten Putin ihrer kennen wir alle es
ist die im Mai 2018 feierlich eröffnete
Creme Brücke über die Straße von catch
[Applaus]
wir sprechen hier über das Kronjuwel der
russischen Infrastruktur als treue
visualpolitik Zuschauer wisst ihr sicher
schon seit langem das Rost an einem
Ernstes infrastrukturproblem im ganzen
Land hat vor allem wenn es um Brücken
geht nun jetzt kann Russland sagen das
ist die längste Brücke Europas gebaut
hat ein Grundstück das bisher den
Portugiesen mit der Vasco di Gamma
Brücke in Lissabon vorbei behalten war
die Brücke von Kersch verbindet
zumindest als dieses Video aufgenommen
wurde noch Russland mit der Halbinsel
Grimm auf einer Länge von 19 km bis 2022
wurde sie täglich von mehr als 15.000
Autos überquert diese Brücke ist die
Nabelschnur die die kill mit Russland
verbindet und sie hat auch die
Wirtschaft der Insel angekommen und
daher stellt sich selbstverständlich die
Frage was würden eigentlich die Bewohner
der Krim davon halten wenn sie wieder
von Russland abgenabelt wirken würden
würden sie zum Beispiel im Falle eines
echten demokratischen Referendums wieder
dafür stimmen weiterhin Teile Russland
zu sein oder eher dafür in den Schoß der
Ukraine zurückzukehren oder wollen Sie
eher ganz unabhängig werden aber eines
nach dem anderen schließlich wissen wer
bereits dass die Bevölkerung der Krim
alles andere als homogen ist und
Vorsicht wir sprechen hierbei immer noch
nur über die Menschen die dort vor der
russischen Annexion 2014 gelebt haben
bei allen danach zugezogenen Russen
handelt es sich nämlich um
illegale Einwanderer den meisten von
ihnen droht daher sollte Russland die
Herrschaft über die Krim wieder
verlieren die Abschiebung zurück in ihre
russische Heimat für die Integration der
Grimm in die Ukraine und ihre
terrorifizierung die ähnlich ablaufen
soll wie die denazifizierung Deutschland
nach dem Zweiten Weltkrieg hat Präsident
die sogar eine Sonderbotschafterin
Berufen ihr Name ist Camila Tasche war
und sie ist krank
wenn sie nicht gehen landen sie vor dem
Internationalen Strafgerichtshof sie
sind Teil der russischen
Kolonialisierung und sind Komplizen der
russischen Aggression es gibt bereits
detaillierte Pläne für die Operation der
Krim Tasche war zusammen mit Juristen
Pädagogen und vielen anderen Experten
eine krämerückgewinnung Strategie
arbeitet die eine befreite weltoffen und
saubere Krim zum modernen europäischen
Urlaubsort machen soll
Antworten auch Arbeitsgruppen
eingerichtet die die derungsifizierung
das seit 2014 verlorenen oder
illegal erworbenen Eigentum
sicherstellen sollen Kollaborateur und
Besatzer sollen nämlich nicht materiell
vom russischen Unrecht profitieren und
die alten Eigentümer zum Beispiel die
printertaren müssen die Möglichkeit
bekommen wieder in ihre alten Häuser
zurückzukehren was die kindertaren
angeht dürfte also sowieso klar sein auf
besten Seite sie stehen aber was ist mit
dem Rest der Krim Bevölkerung nun und
deren Befindlichkeiten zu ergründen
müssen wir noch mal kurz in die Zeit
nach 2014 Zurückgehen der unter der
Aufsicht der spitznas gewählte neuer
Ministerpräsident von Putins Gnaden
Aktion auf der noch immer regiert war
noch in den 1990er Jahren ein
berüchtigter und brutaler Mafioso mit
dem Spitznamen der Kobold das war
eigentlich nur logisch dass in der
Obermarkt Joseph Putin als den
Vollstrecker seine Agenda ausert
schließlich brauchte jemanden der
unbarmherzigt durchgreifen kann und
Axion of Legende gleich los nur eine
Woche nach seiner Ernährung wurde recht
hat am Mittwoch einen Kredit drei
Männern in Militäruniformen in ein
Fahrzeug gezerrt und entführt seine mit
Handschellen gefesselte und mit
schlagwunden übersäte Leiche wurde
später in einem Waldstück gefunden und
niemand wurde wegen seines Todes
angeklagt obwohl die Gesichter der
Entführer in online-aufnahmen seiner
Entführung zu sehen sind ganz ähnlich er
ging es dutzenden weitere Aktivisten die
nicht mit der russischen Besatzung der
Chor waren die ganze Halbinsel wurde mit
einem dichten Netz ein Spitzel überzogen
den nichts entgeht Putin und Aktion auf
haben die Creme in einem Minis
verwirrt-unionistischer Prägung
verwandelt ähnlich wie es auch in
Separatisten Republiken im Don Bass der
Fall war wir haben darüber bereits in
einem Video berichtet dass ich euch
natürlich verlinken werde die Besatzer
zwangen einen Jungen aus sie Alter sich
verlaufender Kamera für seine Worte wir
sind für die Ukraine zu entschuldigen
die Russen haben einen jungen Mann
festgenommen der in einer öffentlichen
Meinungsumfrage auf der Krim sagte er
habe keine Angst vor einer gegen
Offensive der Streitkräfte und
unterstütze die Ukraine
strafverfolgungsbeamte der vorübergehend
besetzten halbin zwangen den jungen sich
vor der Kamera zu entschuldigen das
soziale Netzwerk versichert dass es sich
um einen 16-jährigen Schüler handelt
Rede und Meinungsfreiheit wurden auf der
Krim abgeschafft russland hat die
Zivilgesellschaft ergrenzt Zombie
fixiert die meisten Menschen fühlen sich
nur noch wie ein Teil einer grauen Masse
und von der ursprünglichen Russland
Euphorie ist bei ihnen auch nicht viel
geblieben ich gehöre zu denjenigen die
beim Referendum 2014 mit Jahr gestimmt
haben damals glaubte ich aufrichtig
daran das wird Teil eines großen Landes
werden es ist daher unwahrscheinlich
dass die alt eingesessenen russischen
grimmbewohner den ukrainischen Truppen
Widerstand leisten werden wenn diese die
Halbinsel einnehmen denn im Gegensatz zu
den illegal eingewanderten Russen haben
sie ja schließlich schon früher in der
Ukraine gelebt und wissen daher dass die
Krämer Propaganda über Nazis in der
Ukraine Bullshit ist sie sind sich
mittlerweile auch dessen bewusst dass
Putin sie vom Rest der Welt isoliert und
wirtschaftlich von den Almosen aus einem
staatssekel abhängig gemacht hat ihnen
ist daher klar dass die sowieso keine
nach nachhaltig und dauerhafte Lösungen
für ihre Lage sein kann weil jetzt wo
ihre Wasserversorgung über den von den
Russen gesprengten karowka staudamen
nicht mehr gesichert ist übrigens
kleiner fun fact wisst ihr wer 1787 für
Zaren Katharina die Große die Grimm
erobert hat kein geringerer als Fürst
potent kennt nachdem die berühmten
Portion kitchendorfer benannt sind und
diese nur aus Fassaden und Statisten
bestehenden Faktor verließ er wo
errichten um Katharina auf ihre
Durchreise zu beeindrucken Bingo auf der
Krim die Krim ist also der original
Standorte potention Dörfer und während
für die ganze Welt Polte das Synonym für
den griechischen Höfling ist der für die
Zaren ein falsches Bild von der Realität
entwirft ist der Vergleiche mir Putin
eine russische nationalistische Held der
die Creme und da war das Wahrzeichen der
imperialen Gloria Russlands es entbehrt
er nicht eine gewissen Ironie das ist
eben putin ist der auf ebenso
kriecherische höfliche herausgefallen
ist die im weismachen wollten er könnte
die Ukraine im Handstreich nehmen und
die ihm wohl immer noch erzählen er für
diesen Krieg irgendwie gewinnen und auf
ganz ähnliche Weise machten auch die
Lakaien des Kreml aus der Kremmen wieder
eine brötchenkinsche Halbinsel auf der
alles Blitzen soll vor allem im Grunde
genommen nichts richtig funktioniert wie
gesagt die Bewohner haben aber
mittlerweile begriffen dass sie in einer
russischen fake-realität Leben das von
Moskau errichtete Fassaden aus
subventionierten Wohltaten keine
Substanz aufweisen und irgendwann in
sich zusammenbrechen werden auf Schritt
und Tritt gibt es Hindernisse aufgrund
von Sanktionen ich kann meine
Kreditkarte benutzen aber nicht
international es gibt einen Flughafen
und ein Bahnhof aber man kann nur nach
Russland fahren man kann ein Taxi rufen
aber es ist als wäre man im Jahr 2005
ebenso vergegenwärtigen Sie sich dass
sie nun unabhängig davon ob sie
freiwillig oder unfreiwillig für den
Anschluss an Russland bestimmt haben
Teil eines terrorfilms sind an dessen
Händen das Blut aber Tausender ihrer
ehemaligen und vielleicht auch
zukünftigen lassen Leute erklärt ich
habe Familie in Person und es bricht mir
das Herz mit ihnen zu telefonieren denn
ihr Leben hat sich in einen Albtraum
verwandelt für die meisten von ihnen
haben sich nicht nur die versprochenen
Hoffnung nicht erfüllt nein es ist für
sie alles nur noch ein Albtraum der so
schnell wie möglich Vorbeigehen soll und
sie wissen eben auch dass es putin war
der diesen Albtraum entfesselt und sie
in ihn hinein geworfen hat wenn die
krime also aus dem totalitären Mafia
Start Russland wieder herausgelöst sind
werden sie eher erleichtert sein und
einfach ihr Leben weiterleben wollen
ihre größte Sorge ist jedoch dass sie
zuvor von Putin gegen die Ukraine
mobilisiert werden könnten wenn die
Schlacht um die Krämer losgeht denn
Putins Paranoia die Halbinsel wieder zu
verlieren ist so gewaltig dass man sich
sogar aus dem Weltraum deutlich erkennen
kann Moskau hat diese Halbinsel in einem
wahren militärische Festung verwandelt
im Norden oder ein ausgedehntes Netz und
Schützengräben und Befestigungsanlagen
ausgehoben während im Westen ein 20 km
langer Strandabschnitt mit
Verteidigungsanlagen im Spiel ist Nazi
Atlantik weiß in der Normandie übersät
ist dieser macht die Angst da draußen
vor einer antibiischen Invasion der
Ukraine deutlich und daher kommen wir
jetzt zu der Frage auf die sicher alle
gewartet haben kann die Ukraine die
Creme wirklich zurückerobern spitzt die
Ohren
[Applaus]
die Geographie eine zwei schneidiges
Schwert
es gibt mehr als 130 Flüsse und Bäche
die in den Bergen der Krimis springen
und doch leidet diese Halbinsel seit
Jahren unter Wasserknappheit zu Beginn
dieses Videos haben wir ja gesagt dass
die Creme allein aufgrund ihrer
Geographie wie eine uneinnehmbare
Festung wirkt gleichzeitig ist dies aber
auch ihre Achillesferse die einzige
Möglichkeit die Creme auf dem Landweg zu
versorgen sind die Straßen die sie mit
der Ukraine verbinden oder eben die
Brücke von Cash oder der Punkt ist das
beide Arterien relativ leicht angreifbar
sind in der Tat wurden sie bereits
angegriffen die Brücke von Kersch die
Russland mit der Creme verbindet wurde
bei einer Explosion beschädigt aber das
ist noch nicht alles erinnert ihr euch
noch daran dass die nur durch wenige
Punkte mit der Ukraine verbunden ist ein
solcher Punkt ist die Halbinsel schon
Haare die fast die berührt hier gibt es
eine kleine Brücke über die eine
Schnellstraße führt und schaut mal was
da schon wiederholt passiert ist
Ukraine greift schon Hardbrücke zur
krimin an sagt Russland 6 August 2023
die Brücke über mehr enge von handices
zu arrabattnehrung und liegt schon
Hardbrücke über die seawatch Bucht
zwischen der Krim und dem Gebiet Carson
wurden nach Angriffen der
Besatzungsbehörden beschlossen in all
diesen Fällen handelt es sich bisher um
sehr begrenzte Angriffe die Schäden sind
relativ leicht zu beheben aber sie sagen
uns eines die Ukraine ist aus ihrer
derzeitigen Position in der Lage beide
Ziele anzugreifen der Schaden an der
John Hardbrücke ist von großer Bedeutung
erstellt einen Schlag für die
militärische Logistik der Besatzer da
noch wichtiger ist die psychologische
Wirkung auf die Besatzer und die
Besatzungstruppen in der Region herson
gibt es keinen Ort an dem Sie sich
sicher fühlen können bisher musste sie
hier zu teure Langstrecken Artillerie
macht Schluck Körper und Drohnen
einsetzen aber stellt euch vor was
passieren würde wenn die ukrainische
Streitkräfte noch näher an dieses Gebiet
heranrücken dann würden sie diese neuen
Punkte sehr einfach durch massiven und
billigen artilleriebeschluss
kontrollieren ohne dass die Russen etwas
dagegen unternehmen könnten und genau
aus diesem Grund konzentriert sich eine
großer Teil der ukrainischen gegen
Offensive auf die Eliminierung der
russischen Artillerie und genau auf
diese Stoßrichtung
je weiter die Ukraine in der Region
saporisha Richtung meltopold vorrücken
desto einfacher wird es für sie alle
Verbindungswege zur Creme anzugreifen
bis dahin ist es im Rahmen der
ukrainischen Strategie des permanenten
langanhaltenden Druck sie doch klüger
andere Ziele auf der krimit
Langstreckenwaffen anzugreifen vor allem
munitions- und Treibstoff der Post und
andere Logistikzentren auf der Halbinsel
liegen sie quasi wie auf einem
Silbertablett bereit nacheinander
ausgeschaltet zu werden erst später
macht es dann Sinn die Creme auch von
anderen Ressourcen abzuschneiden apropos
Ressourcen die Wasserversorgung der
Creme eines der wichtigsten Kriegsziele
der Russen haben sie sich selbst mit der
Sprengung des Kaufhof Karte Darms
abgedreht aber darüber haben wir bereits
in eine früheren Video gesprochen dass
ich euch verlinken werde sollte sich die
Ukraine schließlich also dazu
entschließen die beiden versorgungsarten
zur Grenze unterbrechen könnten Russland
seine kostbare Halbinsel nur noch auf
dem Seeweg versorgen sowie eins die
Wehrmacht vor der Schlacht um die Krems
und wie das ausgegangen ist haben wir
euch schon im ersten Teil dieses Videos
erzählt tatsächlich zeigt sich gerade
während der letzten Tage das Russland
schwarzen drauf und dran ist vollkommen
nutzlos zu werden Angriffe mit See
Drohnen jetzt schlägt Ukraine Russland
mit seinen eigenen Waffen erst ein
Kriegsschiff dann ein Öltanker für
Russland ist das Schwarze Meer nicht
mehr sicher seitdem die Ukraine See
Drohnen einsetzt die Ukraine
intensivieren damit ihre Angriffe im
Schwarzen Meer und zeigen dass ihr neu
entwickelten See Drohnen eine Bedrohung
für die russische Schifffahrt im Norden
des binnenmeers darstellen Ukraine 6
russische schwarzmeerhefen im
kriegsrisikogebiet in einer Erklärung
auf ihrer Website erklärte die Agentur
die Warnung gelte für die Häfen
und tamam die Russen könnten also in
wirklich extreme Bedrängnis geraten denn
es ist fast unmöglich Treibstoff
Munition in großen Mengen per Flugzeug
zu liefern mit anderen Worten es besteht
die Möglichkeit dass die Ukraine die
Krim erstmal logistisch abschneidet und
dann einfach ein paar Monate lang wartet
so wie ist die Rote Armee 1943 auch Tat
nach und nach würde den russischen
Truppen auf der Krimi dann die Mitte zu
Verteidigung ausgehen und in diesem
Punkt wäre es einfacher einen
Bodenangriff zu starten aber wie könnte
dieser dann gestaltet sein genau das
werden wir jetzt in detail
auseinandernehmen aufgepasst
die neue Schlacht um die Krems
[Musik]
also wie könnte eine Bodenoffensive zur
Einnahme der Krim Aussehen nun zum einen
könnte es sich natürlich einfach um eine
Operation mit roher Masse und Gewalt im
reinsten D-Day Stil handeln so wie es
auch die Sowjets gegen die Nazis
vorgeführt haben die Ukraine müsste dazu
jedoch eine große Anzahl von Truppen
Insekten wohl wissen dass sie damit
tausende von Menschenleben opfern würde
dazu müsste sie diese Truppen anderswo
entbehren können die russische Armee
müsste also in anderen Frontabschnitten
so geschwächt sein dass sie dort
entbehrlich sind ist es möglich dass wir
dieses Szenario erleben werden nun
höchstwahrscheinlich nicht denn dies ist
ganz und gar nicht die Art der Ukraine
das haben sie seit dem Beginn ihrer
verteidigungsanstrengung gegen die
Russen bewiesen wie auch während der
derzeitigen gegen Offensive sie haben im
Gegensatz zu den Russen die Zeichen der
Zeit erkannt dass die demografien bei
der Länder eine Kriegsführung nach dem
Muster der Roten Armee nicht mehr
hergeben weder Russland noch die Ukraine
können es sich leisten massenweise
Männer zu verhalten der Unterschied
zwischen beiden Armenien besteht aber
darin dass die Ukraine diese Erkenntnis
im Rahmen einer intelligenten Strategie
auszunutzen weiß eine Strategie die von
außen noch immer auf missverstanden oder
viel interpretiert wird so wird das
langsame Tempo der gegenwärtigen und
keine schnupfensive als Schwäche oder
von manchen gar als scheitern ausgelegt
wobei aber genau das Gegenteil der Fall
ist es wird die Aufgabe von
militärhistorikern seine retrospektiv zu
beurteilen ob es sich zur Zeit um eine
zahnwirbung oder eher um eine langsame
manöverkampagne zur permanenten
Druckerzeugung handelt eine sehr
langsame druckkampagne kann aber nur
dann erfolgreich sein wenn man viel
Geduld mitbringt sehr viel Geduld und
über diese scheinen die Ukraine zum
Glück zu verfügen schließlich haben sie
auch keine andere Wahl als die eigenen
Verluste zu minimieren während der Druck
auf die russischen Kräfte aufrecht
erhalten wird bisher Logistik Moral und
schließlich auch die Frontlinie jene Art
von Rissen aufweisen die Ukraine dann
ausnutzen können regelmäßige Tests
dieser Risse die dann die gescheiterte
Offensive Operation Aussehen sind fester
Bestand an dieser Strategie in erster
Linie auch davon abhängt dass der besten
die Ukraine über viele Monate hinweg
kontinuierlich mit Ausrüstung versorgt
aus Song kann schließlich ersetzt werden
Soldaten nicht denn wie gesagt verfügt
keine der kompatranten über die
entsprechenden demografischen
Voraussetzungen dafür einzig die Russen
Handeln nicht dementsprechend es geht in
erster Linie auch nicht darum die Russen
zu zermürken sondern viel mehr darum sie
kontinuierlich aus ihren vorbereiteten
Verteidigungsstellungen zu locken und zu
drängen so dass die Ukraine daraus dann
Nutzen ziehen können um operative
Fortschritte zu erzielen falls diese
Strategie in der Region saporisha von
Erfolg gegründet sein wird könnte sie
auch gegen die russischen Besatzung
aufwecken Anwendung finden sobald diese
ausreichend isoliert sind und ihre
Logistik kollabiert und wie schon im
Zweiten Weltkrieg sind hierbei auch
wieder partisanenoperation von
entscheidender Bedeutung
krimpakt designen berichten über die
Bewegung von militärischen Gerät der
Russischen Föderation nach dem ferropol
die dies berichtet die militärische
Untergrundbewegung von Ukraine und Krim
tatarenteich
warum Kämpfer der Grimm Tataren einem
wachsende Rolle im Widerstand gegen die
russische Besatzung spielen die Bewegung
Attest zu deutschfeuer hat sich
verpflichtet einen nicht enden wollenden
Krieg gegen die russischen Invasoren in
der Ukraine zu führen die im September
2022 gegründete artisch Bewegung zielt
darauf ab die Logistik zu stören
wichtige Ziele zu sabotieren und Aufruhr
gegen die russische Armee zu schüren die
Methoden von Attest sind rücksichtslos
wie die Ermordung von 30 russischen
Soldaten in Krankenhäusern in
zimtherapeut im November 2022 beweist
aber ihre Methoden sind auch effektiv im
Februar 2023 behauptet die Gruppe mehr
als 4000 russische Soldaten hätten
bereits Ihren Online Kurs absolviert wie
sie den Krieg durch Sabotage ihre
eigenen Ausrüstung überleben können
Muster weiterhin als partnertarischen
Bürgerrechtsbewegung gilt verweist immer
wieder darauf dass ich die 300.000
Menschen starke Gemeinschaft der Kinder
fahren voll für die Befreiung der Creme
einsetzen werde zunächst aktiv im
Untergrund hinter den russischen Linien
danach aber auch im direkten Kampf
sobald Sie die dafür notwendigen Waffen
erhielten es ist daher davon auszugehen
dass die hochgradig motivierten
Kindertagen eine wesentlich größere
Kampfstärke aufweisen werden als die
ethnische Bevölkerung obwohl diese
zahlenmäßig überlegen scheint ähnlich
weiß ja auch schon beim Überfall auf die
Ukraine im Februar 2022
zusammenfassend kann man also sagen dass
die historischen Erfahrungen der vielen
krim-züge über die wir im ersten Teil
dieses Videos gesprochen haben zeigen
dass die für ein erfolgreiche
Rückeroberung erforderlichen Faktoren
für die Ukraine durchaus darstellbar
sind diese wären die Isolation der Creme
in dem alle Landbrücken durchtrennt
werden das paralysieren der russischen
schwarzen Flotte und damit ist
abschneidende Versorgungswege über mehr
und die Luft Zerstörung der
militärischen Infrastrukturen Logistik
auf der Halbinsel durch ateliergeschoss
und Körper unter Aufbau einer
partisanenorganisation ziel ist es die
Russen durch Isolation und tausend
Nadelstiche zu demonalisieren und ihre
militärischen Fähigkeiten und Reserven
auf ein Minimum zu reduzieren und
sollten Sie die Kinder nicht freiwillig
verlassen so wie sie es im Falle her
sonst hatten kann die Halbinsel über die
vorhin beschriebene druckkampagne im
Rahmen eines langsam bewegungskriegs
befreit werden wobei in diesem Fall auch
mit einem größeren partisanenfaktor zum
Vorteil der Ukraine zu rechnen ist es
gibt zwar auch eine Planung im Rahmen
einer politischen militärischen
Operation ohne einen Boden Offensive zu
befreien indem die Rus zum freiwilligen
Rückzug gezwungen werden aber selbst
wenn hier für die Voraussetzungen
geschaffen sind werden die Russen nicht
abziehen ohne dass eine wirklich reale
militärische Bedrohung für sie erzeugt
wird das war ja auch im Falle her sonst
so diese Bedrohung muss wirklich in
Front tatsächlicher militärischer Stärke
Präsenz Angriffsbereitschaft und
Entschlossenheit existieren und zwar in
einem solch hohen Maß dass ihre
Ausführung auf glaubwürdige Weise
unmittelbar bevorsteht die
Hauptvoraussetzung hierfür ist ihre vor
allem die konstante Waffenhilfe aus dem
Westen in dieser Phase vor allem
weitreichende Körper und Langstrecken
nach Galerie später auch alles weitere
was für ein Manöver kriegt notwendig ist
und eventuell auch Kampfjets vom Typ F
16 und darüber wird diese für die
Ukraine zum Einsatz kommen könnten damit
bald in einem eigenen Video untersuchen
vergesst also bitte nicht das Abo mit
glücklichen um es nicht zu verpassen
tatsächlich Stellen schnelle und
ausreichende Waffenlieferung aus dem
besten den Schlüssel dazu da keinen
gefährlichen und langwierigen Krieg mit
Russland zu riskieren der besten kann
dazu beitragen den Konflikt viel
schneller zu beenden indem er die Waffen
die Ausrüstung und die logistische
Unterstützung liefert die die Ukraine
benötigt um die russischen Truppen aus
allen besitzen Gebieten nördlich der
Grenze vertreiben und Moskau ist
Einfluss auf die Halbinsel glaubhaft zu
bedrohen im Moment schaffte es die
Ukraine auch mit nur mäßiger
Unterstützung des Westens gegen die
Invasoren zu siegen um Putin davon zu
überzeugen dass es besser ist wenn er
sich von der Grenze zurückzieht müssen
die westlichen Länder jedoch noch viel
mehr tun sie müssen alle künstlichen
Beschränkungen aufheben die sie der
militärischen Unterstützung Kiews
auferlegt haben und die
Langstreckenwaffen liefern die erste
Ukraine ermöglichen würden sowohl
offensiv als auch defensiv zu agieren
leider sind viele westliche Politiker in
diesem Punkt immer noch psychisch
blockiert entweder befürchten sie das
Putin atomknopf drückt wenn er kurz
davor stehen könnte die Grenze verlieren
oder dass er den Konflikt so weit
eskalieren würde dass die NATO direkt in
ihn hineingezogen wird die Sticheleien
aus Belarus sind ein Beispiel dafür
tatsächlich sind die Sorgen über einen
Kernwaffeneinsatz vollkommen unbegründet
wir haben schon mehrfach darüber
gesprochen einerseits hätte diese
katastrophale Folgen für Russland und
Putins Regime die weit über den Verlust
der Krim hinausgehen würden nicht nur
wegen der Reaktion des Westen sondern
auch wegen seiner Bündnisse mit China
und anderen Ländern andererseits ist
angesichts der geringen Kontrolle die
Putin über seine eigenen Leute hat nicht
klar ob seine Generäle und Kommandeure
den Befehl überhaupt befolgen würden
dieser Befehl wäre tatsächlich der
letzte den Putin je erteilen würde und
zwar ohne dass es zu seiner Ausführung
käme schließlich handelt es sich um den
ultimativen Befehl um eine Armee wollte
auszulösen und das weiß auch Putin
deswegen ist es auch gar nicht mal so
sehr das russische nukleare Säbelrasseln
das den westlichen Politikern und
Strategen die Sorgenfalten auf die Stirn
treibt viel mehr befürchtet man eine
konventionelle Eskalation gefahren nach
dem musste dass sich die Nato und
Russland mit einer schrittweisen
Erhöhung der militärischen Unterstützung
der Ukraine auf eine direkte
Konfrontation zu bewegen nicht weil
diese irgendjemand gezielt planen würde
sondern weil dadurch das allgemeine
Risiko steigt dass ein Unfall oder eine
viel Einschätzung einen ausgewachsenen
Krieg auslösen könnten deswegen waren
manche Analysten davor dies wäre die
Formel für einen Flächenbrand der die
NATO erreicht und schließlich auch für
eine möglich Eskalation vom
konventionellen zum nuklearen könnte in
Wirklichkeit hat Putin jedoch keinerlei
Interesse an einem direkten Krieg mit
der NATO das hat er schließlich deutlich
gemacht indem er keine konventionelle
militärische Reserve mit Fähigkeiten für
eine solche Konfrontation mehr vorhält
natürlich bedeutet dies nicht dass er
nicht bereit wäre ein gefährliches
Katzen und Mausspiel mit dem besten zu
spielen und je länger sich dieses Spiel
hinzieht desto größer ist die
Wahrscheinlichkeit dass es wirklich zu
einer drei Könige kommt
deswegen ist es eben wichtig die Ukraine
so zügig wie möglich mit allen
notwendigen Waffen zu versorgen mit
denen Sie dieses Spiel beenden kann oder
diesen Punkt angekommen müssen wir uns
letztlich auch die Frage stellen kann es
sich die Ukraine und kann es sich Europa
leisten die Krim links liegen zu lassen
Sie einfach den Russen zu überlassen
nach allem was geschehen ist und vor
allem geschehen könnte nun vielleicht
könnten sie das aber es wäre extrem
schwierig und es würde auf gar keinen
Fall jede Ruhe und jeden Frieden bringen
die sich viele Befürworter einer solchen
piece mit Lösung vorstellen solange die
Krebs zu Russland gehört wird nicht nur
niemanden hier ruhig schlafen können
nein es wird auch keinen Frieden in
Europa geben selbst nach einem
Waffenstillstand oder gar Fries abkommen
würde Moskau weiterhin das also für mehr
kontrollieren es könnte jederzeit wieder
die ukrainischen Getreide Exporte
bedrohen außerdem hätte Russland
weiterhin eine perfekte Militärbasis und
erneut in die Ukraine einzunehmen oder
sie zumindest zu terrorisieren und zu
bombardieren Europa würde dadurch
außerdem die große Schuss verwehrt
bleiben durch die Erschließung der
Erdgasfelder im schwarzen wir einen
neuen starken und demokratischen
Lieferanten von Energie direkt vor der
Haustür zu bekommen es ist schon ebenso
erstaunlich wie aufschlussreich das von
all den selben friedensforschern und
Friedensaktivisten die die europäischen
Kopplung von russischen
Energielieferungen kritisieren und die
Anis für deren Abneigung gegenüber den
nostryplatz angreifen gar nichts zu
hören war als Putin durch seine Don Bass
und creme Invasion die ukrainische
erdgaskonkurrenz für Europa kalt stellte
plötzlich wenn es nicht aus Russland
kommt ist Ihnen dieses Gas nicht mehr so
wichtig ja wie sagt man so schön wessen
Brot essen Lied ich sehe aber natürlich
geht es bei der cremefrage für Europa
nicht nur um günstiges Erdgas und
Energie Unabhängigkeit nein es geht für
die gesamte freie Welt darum dass ein
Verbleiben der Grimm in den Händen aus
Russland die gesamte bisherige Regel
basierte Weltordnung in Frage stellen
würde vielleicht handelt es sich sogar
um das wichtigste geostrategische
Prinzip unserer Zeit die Garantie dafür
dass ich nicht jede stärkere macht
einfach herausnehmen kann einen
kleineren Staat zu überfallen und sein
per rektorium zu annektieren der Kampf
um die Unabhängigkeit der Ukraine und
die Wiederherstellung ihrer
territorialen Integrität ist auch ein
Kampf um die Wiederherstellung des
sinns- und zwecks der un-katar denn wenn
ein ständiges Mitglied Sicherheitsrates
eine Atommacht eine Aggression gegen
einen kleineren Nachbarn anführt dann
stellt dies die Frage wozu die Welt
überhaupt ein Sicherheitsrat oder die
UNO als Ganzes braucht ein Sieg
Russlands in Form territorialer Gewinne
würde also das Ende der seit 1945
bestehenden Weltordnung darstellen und
dessen sind sich natürlich auch die Atom
und unbit möchte Indien und hier bewusst
deswegen nahmen sie auch an den
Friedensgesprächen in Saudi Arabien Teil
womit sie sich letztlich hinter die
Position der Ukraine und ihre
territorale Integrität gestellt haben
das Schicksal der Krim wird
ausschlaggebend dafür sein welche Lehren
aus diesen Krieg gezogen werden und in
welche Richtung sich die Welt durch
seinen Ausgang verändert wird die
Halbinsel Grimm ist der entscheidende
Schauplatz dieses Krieges und dann mit
ihrer letztendliche Befreiung die Tötung
aller russischen Soldaten im Umkreis von
100 Kilometern um bachmut ändert
strategisch nichts die Befreiung der
Krim ändert alles generalleutmann ade
benotics ehemaliger Befehlshaber der
US-Armee in Europa aus diesem Grund wird
es keinen nachhaltigen Frieden in Europa
geben können wenn nicht alle Territorien
die vor 2013 Ukraine gehört haben von
der russischen Herrschaft bereits sind
es wird keinen Frieden geben wenn die
Ukraine nicht in Sicherheit leben können
in Sicherheit vor Terroranschlägen von
Beschuss und Raketen diese Sicherheit
bedeutet dass Ihre Flughäfen wieder
öffnen die Flüchtlinge zurückkehren
ausländische Investitionen wieder
aufgenommen und Gebäude wieder aufgebaut
werden können ohne dass man befürchten
muss dass eine weitere russische Rakete
sie zerstört oder um diese Art von
Sicherheit zu erreichen braucht die
Ukraine mehr als einen Waffenstillstand
das Land muss in eine
Sicherheitsstruktur eingebettet werden
die so verlässlich ist dass man ihr
wirklich vertrauen kann etwas dass der
NATO ähnelt wenn ich sogar die NATO
selbst die Ukraine wird sich wieder als
Frau starte Israel oder Südkorea
verstehen müssen mit einer
Verteidigungsindustrie von Weltrang und
einem großen stehenden Heer denn real
existierende Abschreckung ist die
wichtigste Garantie für den Frieden
Frieden in Europa wird das nur dann
geben können wenn die russische Führung
die russischen Eliten und die Mehrheit
des russischen Volkes zum Schluss kommen
dass der Krieg ein katastrophaler Fehler
Ihrerseits war und Russland die Ukraine
als unabhängiges Land mit einem Recht
auf Existenz von territoriale Integrität
anerkennen muss wenn man diese katalysis
Russland aber nicht auch sehr teuerem
Wege durch eine gewaltsame
bedingungslose Kapitulation Übersetzung
Kolonialmächte Frankreich und
Großbritannien im Laufe des 20
Jahrhunderts durchgemacht haben
wohlgemerkt in Frankreich ging dieser
Gesinnungswandel nicht ohne den
Zusammenbruch der alten
Verfassungsordnung Attentatsversuchen
und einem gescheiterten her was aber ist
der Schlüssel dazu um die Russen zur
Einsicht zu bringen dass der eigene
kolonial Ismus Imperialismus
Nationalismus und Militarismus auch
schlecht für sie selbst ist und nicht
mehr in diese Welt gehört dass diese
toxische Gesinnung einfach alle Mal auch
in Russland aus der Mode kommen muss so
wie sie in den übrigen ehemaligen
imperialen Kolonialmächten aus der Mode
gekommen ist nun genau das erfahrt ihr
jetzt
der Schlüssel heißt
in der Tat der Schlüssel heißt Krim die
russische Annexion der Krim im Jahr 1783
inspirierte Putins Liebe zu pottian
kennen und seine eigene Annexion im Jahr
2014 hat seine Präsidentschaft im
Inneren Russland 9 Schwung verliehen der
Slogan kriminalstieg Grimm gehört uns
verbreitete sich in einem Ausbruch
imperialistischer Emotionen und so wird
es wahrscheinlich Nostalgie in ganz
Russland wurde Teil der russischen
Popkultur ähnlich wie heute gehört uns
Deutschland und morgen die ganze Welt
seiner Zeit unter den Nazis der Verlust
der Grimm wird also zwar kein
hinreichendes Kriterium darstellen um
ein aufgeklärtes und friedliches
Russland zu errichten dass endlich auch
in unserem modernen Welt passt aber er
ist ein bitter notwendiges Kriterium
ganz genau ohne die Krim wieder
abzutreten kann Russland wieder
demokratisch noch freiheitlich werden
sich selbst von der eigenen sprach
Schuld und Schande seine Barbarei in der
Ukraine reinigen und an dieser Stelle
kommt die Frage auf was dieses abtreten
eigentlich bedeutet klar ist das
Russland die Kontrolle vor allem die
militärische über die Krämpfe verlieren
muss das steht großer Frage im Falle von
Friedensverhandlungen wird es jedoch
sicherlich unterschiedliche Modelle und
Szenarien geben wie es mit der Creme
weitergehen könnte so könnte durchaus
der Fall eintreten dass eine
militärische Rückeroberung für die
Ukraine in der Tat zu teuer werden
könnte es könnte der Moment kommen an
dem Russland zwar quasi geschlagen ist
aber auch die ukrainische Öffentlichkeit
sich die Frage stellt wie viele ihrer
Soldaten noch dafür sterben sollen die
Krim durch eine Bodenoffensive wieder zu
erobern und in einer solchen Fall könnte
in der Tat ein Sonderstatus für die
Halbinsel ausgehandelt werden
fast in den ersten Teil dieses Videos
nicht verpasst habt werdet ihr euch noch
daran erinnern wie der kring Krieg 1856
ausgegangen ist in Friedensvertrag von
Paris stimmte Russland der
Neutralisierung und Demilitarisierung
seiner Schwarzmeerküste inklusive der
Creme zu damit es die Chance eines
Neuanfangs bekam ähnlich könnten auch
jetzt Friedensverhandlungen eine
unabhängige und entmilitarisierte Creme
als neuen Start hervorbringen die weder
russisch noch Ukrainisch ist Ihre
Garantie macht könnte dann z.B das neue
hochgerüstete NATO Mitglied Ukraine sein
diese neutrale freie und unabhängige
Creme könnte mit ihren Erdgasfeldern und
auch als Urlaubsort sowohl für Russen
als auch für die übrigen Europäer dann
so eine Art demokratischen Katar oder
Dubai aussehen sie könnte eine blendende
Zukunft vor sich haben und Europa hätte
endlich seinen wohl verdienten Frieden
na so schön um wirklich wahr zu werden
nun die Frage ist natürlich inwieweit
Überlegungen über fruchtbare und
zielführende Friedensverhandlungen
überhaupt realistisch sind das
Grundproblem bei all diesen Debatten
über eine vier Verhandlungslösung ist
nämlich dass der Westen immer noch nicht
begreift was das Ziel und der Kern von
Putins Aggression ist die ursprünglich
angekündigte Entnazifizierung der
Ukraine ist natürlich Unsinn und wird
von niemandem mathematisiert der Kreml
stellt den Krieg nun als präventivkampf
gegen eine westliche hegemoniale
Bedrohung da aber auch das ist kein
wirklich greifbares Ziel über das man
verhandeln könnte wenn putinskrieg aber
kein Ziel hat dann ist das Ziel der
Krieg selbst 23 Jahre der Herrschaft
Putins liegen nahe das Konfrontation und
Krieg für ihn selbstverständlich sind
das alles was er tat auf nichts anderes
als Krieg hinaus gelaufen ist Krieg und
Konfrontation sind zu den hauptmitteln
geworden um sich überhaupt an der Macht
zu halten er kann sich aus diesen Krieg
nicht mehr zurückziehen wenn kein
autoritärer Führer kann einen Krieg
verlieren und trotzdem ein autoritärer
Führer bleiben Putin spielt um sein
politisches Überleben und sein
historisches Erbe unter diesen
Voraussetzungen ist es aber
unwahrscheinlich das Putin Russland
einer Lösung zustimmen würde die
Nachrichten dauerhaften Frieden
garantiert er würde immer einen Fehler
einbauen sich ein Hintertürchen
freihalten ohne den Konflikt und den
Krieg wieder neu aufzufachen nein
Russland selbst muss an einer Art
umfassenden Friedensabkommen
interessiert sein aus eigenem Interesse
und das ist eine Sache die wir mit Putin
nur sehr schwer erleben werden er
erkennt die Ukraine nicht allzu
brennendes Land sondern nur als ein
Gebiet das aufgrund eines historischen
Fehlers nicht unter der Kontrolle im
Moskau stand Putin signalisiert mit
allem was er tut dass er diesen Kriege
weiterführen will dass er von seinen wer
weiß was für Zielen nicht abrücken wird
dass er weiterhin bereit ist
wirtschaftliche Verluste in Kauf zu
nehmen er rechnet nämlich auch immer
damit dass der politische Wille im
Westen sich doch noch erschöpfen wird so
dass die materielle politische und
moralische Unterstützung der Ukraine
versiegt er wartet nur darauf dass uns
irgendwie daran gewöhnen werden das
Russland einfach einen Teil der Ukraine
behalten wird er will den Westen dazu
bringen eine Art von Kompromiss zu
bestimmen der für ihn vorteilhaft sein
wird und er sich dann nehmen kann was er
will seine Vision ist es dass die
normative Kraft des praktischen für ihn
arbeitet und genau das ist es was der
besten um jeden Preis verhindern muss
[Musik]
sollten diese und künftige ukrainische
offensiven also keine größeren Erfolge
erzielen muss sich der besten auf einen
sehr langen Krieg Einstellen der
mindestens ein weiteres Jahrzehnt dauern
wird bzw so lange wie Puten an der Macht
bleibt genau das müssen sich all jene
die vor einer Eskalation warnen
vergegenwärtigen sollte die
Unterstützung der Ukraine weiterhin von
Putins roten Linien beeinflusst werden
wird das von ihm zelebrierte und
exekutierte Unrecht zur Norm nicht nur
für die Ukraine sondern für Europa und
die Welt so nun wisst ihr wieso die
Creme wieder mal nicht nur ein Zankapfel
ist sondern der Schlüssel für einen
dauerhaften und haltbaren Frieden in
Europa aber was meint ihr glaubt ihr es
wird nötig sein dass die Ukraine die
Creme militärisch befreit werden die
Russen vielleicht friedlich abziehen
oder wird man am Ende einen Sonderstatus
für die Halbinsel aushandeln können und
so welche Lösung wird eurer Meinung nach
Putin bereits sein werden die fröhlichen
Raver wieder auf der Creme abtanzen
können und welche Position sollte der
besten einnehmen wie immer sind auf eure
Diskussion zu diesem Thema schon mächtig
gespannt ich hoffe dass euch dieses
Video gefallen hat und ihr vielleicht
etwas dabei gelernt habt falls ja gibt
es bitte ein Leid Freunden und
diskutiert es mit ihm natürlich können
wir uns auch jederzeit über eine Spende
von euch mit uns hält dieses Projekt
weiterzuführen den Link dazu findet ihr
in der Beschreibung unter dem Video
macht's gut und bis bald
[Musik]